bueno
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo en redes sociales se promueve
sin control todo tipo de curas mágicas
son milagrosas contra el kobe 19 desde
medicamentos que ni siquiera atacan el
virus hasta sustancias que son nocivas
para la salud y aunque los expertos han
desmentido frecuentemente la efectividad
de estos falsos tratamientos y han
instado a seguir las recomendaciones de
las autoridades la promoción de estos
productos continúa y lo que es peor no
pocos usuarios de internet siguen
dejándose llevar por estas teorías aquí
les brindamos las herramientas para que
usted no caiga en la desinformación y lo
más importante que no juegue con su
salud empezamos colombia fue uno de los
focos de la polémica por el imprudente
uso de dióxido de cloro para tratar el
kobe 19 sin ningún soporte científico la
reconocida modelo natalia parís dijo en
su cuenta de instagram que ella y sus
amigos consumen esta sustancia para
combatir el virus aseguró que nadie se
ha intoxicado y sin pruebas agregó que
gracias a ellos se salvaron muchos
pacientes en perú
que las autoridades sanitarias de ese
país prohibieron su uso al carecer de
efectividad contra el virus y mostrar
efectos adversos para la salud
la desinformación sobre el uso de
dióxido de cloro se promueve en américa
latina' facebook que es propietario de
instagram dice que busca eliminar
afirmaciones como estas una medida que
hace parte de su política contra la
información errónea sobre el virus que
según dice podría provocar daños a la
salud france24 consultó a instagram
latinoamérica sobre por qué al pasar
varios días no se habían tomado acciones
al respecto en el comunicado que ven en
pantalla la compañía nos respondió
diciendo que el comentario vio las
políticas que están al tanto de que los
usuarios pueden verlo y que estaban
trabajando para resolverlo sin embargo
horas después de este pronunciamiento
fue la misma modelo quien lo eliminó de
su cuenta por orden de las autoridades
colombianas
pero cómo funciona exactamente el
dióxido de cloro y qué efectos provoca
en nuestro organismo nos lo explica el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez asesor
científico de france24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia
las sustancias que tienen cloro como el
hipoclorito de sodio o este sustancias
que son como el dióxido de cloro se han
utilizado porque tienen efectos sobre
virus bacterias o gérmenes en
superficies es decir en sustancias
inertes pero eso no se ha probado en
sustancias vivas en material orgánico es
el material inorgánico estas sustancias
cloradas podrían no tener ningún efecto
o podrían ser tóxicas porque si se toman
en forma de inadecuadas las dosis no son
o simplemente esta sustancia tiene una
concentración inadecuada del cloro
pueden producir enfermedades tóxicas
puede intoxicarse la persona y traer
efectos deletéreos en la salud que no ha
demostrado que tengan un beneficio ni
contra virus ni contra bacterias
absolutamente científicamente y en los
registros clínicos no hay evidencia de
eso hay muchas anécdotas pero no hay ese
sentido
días atrás otra supuesta medicina
alternativa contra el kobe 19 fue
presentada en venezuela por el
presidente nicolás maduro se trata de
carba civil una sustancia derivada del
tomillo la definido como gotitas
milagrosas y la atribuyó la capacidad de
neutralizar el virus en un 100% maduro
dijo que el producto ha pasado por
estudios y aplicación clínica en
enfermos con corona virus pero los
expertos critican que no existe
evidencia científica al respecto y
además no se conocen testimonios de
pacientes que hayan sido tratados con
carvatt y vivir ante las críticas del
mandatario pareció retractarse y luego
dijo que este era un tratamiento
complementario la academia nacional de
medicina en venezuela explicó que una
sustancia como ésta tiene el potencial
terapéutico contra el coronavirus y que
sin embargo es prudente esperar por
mayores datos el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez nos explica
hay varios tipos de sustancias como
sustancias que son derivados de
extractos naturales la mayoría de
medicamentos pueden venir de estos
extractos que pueden tener una tía in
vitro qué quiere decir eso que en la
experimentación en los tubos de ensayo
no puede demostrar que se eliminan
cierto tipo se inactiva cierto tipo de
virus cosas que sabes suceden con este
antiviral o que sucede con liberar make
tina o con otras sustancias pero que sea
in vitro que sea en un laboratorio es
diferente a que sea in vivo dentro de
las personas para que algo que sea in
vitro funcione en vivo se requieren años
de estudio de comprobación y se requiere
un estudio juicioso clínico no anécdotas
no redes sociales no canales nada de lo
que circula en internet ni bebidas
mágicas ni amuletos tampoco el consumo
excesivo de ajo o enjuagarse la nariz
regularmente funcionan para prevenir el
coi 19 según la organización mundial de
la salud no existe evidencia de ello a
excepción de las vacunas y las medidas
de bioseguridad que han sido aprobadas
por las autoridades sanitarias además de
poner en riesgo sus
usted podría estar siendo víctima de una
estafa
los medios de comunicación han abordado
las críticas contra medicamentos que
tienen registro sanitario para tratar
otras enfermedades pero sobre los cuales
hay dudas para usarse contra el joven 19
el periódico brasileño folha de sao
paulo recoge el relato de médicos y
pacientes sobre efectos graves del
llamado tratamiento precoz contra el cob
y 19 y que incluye medicamentos como la
ivermectina utilizada como un
desparasitante el comercio de ecuador
titula que según científicos esta
medicina nos sirve para prevenir el kobe
19 la razón de bolivia dice que
intensivistas piden no usar medicamentos
tiene efectividad demostrada contra el
kobe 19 y en colombia el diario
portafolio titula que el invima que es
la autoridad reguladora de medicamentos
no ha autorizado tratamientos contra el
cob y 19 en el país
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
france24 puntocom
[Música]